[Music]  why do you  keep closing your laptop every time i  walk by  you look stressed  work's been uh crazy  i've always wanted to change the world  how  amazon for drugs  but you can't buy drugs on the internet  what if you could  using bitcoin i just made 75 grand  in the last 90 minutes babe that's 1.2  million  a day  this guy's the first millennial gangster  you're gonna crack this the  old-fashioned way asian podium  everything they know they learned off a  screen  not staring down the barrel of a gun  experience matters oh  when you snatch them up send me a fax  the dark net something special came in  the mail  game is changing it's gonna be every  suburb in america  this website needs to be shut down  immediately  i'm the one's gonna bring this brick  down  you crossed this lab and ain't no going  back  you're getting obsessive  we get him on conspiracy to commit  murder  checkmate come on hold your breath  this thing is going to outlive all of us  [Music]  wow bye